[Music]
it's been a minute did you miss us
cuz we missed you you didn't miss
anything get ready for the drama the
first trailer for season 15 of Keeping
Up with the Kardashians is finally here
and it looks like we can expect some
screaming matches and lots of Tears and
Kim's just getting started throwing out
this teaser during a chat with Chloe it
doesn't want to be a Kardashian anymore
shove Kardashian up her vagina so that
happened
meanwhile the family's matriarch Kris
Jenner and her daughter Kendall Jenner
get into a heated conv about Kendall's
dad Caitlyn Jenner he's still part of
our but it's not all drama Kylie Jenner
gushes over motherhood obsessed with
being a mom and fans get a sneak peek at
Kim's newborn daughter Chicago West et
recently caught up with the mom of three
st. and Chicago's relationship is so
sweet that I don't I don't know what's
gonna top that who also dished on big
sister North Schumer like you work on
you now that she's 5 DC which which
characteristic she she's a Gemini says
she's a little bit of both she
definitely has Kanye's outgoing
personality and will say whatever is on
her mind
no matter what it is or who it might
offend and then she's also really common
sweet like me sometimes the best of both
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]